le modèle de la concurrence pure et
parfaite s'appuie sur quatre hypothèses
fondamentales
les entreprises sont tout d'abord
renault-ze de prix il y a tellement
d'entreprises présentes sur le marché
chacune d'elles produisant une si petite
part de la production totale qu'au final
aucune ne peut influer sur le prix du
marché au prix du marché
chaque entreprise est face à une groupe
de demandes horizontale du côté de la
demande
un grand nombre d'acheteurs sont
également présents sur le marché on dit
qu'il ya une atomicité des agents et les
décisions donc de chaque consommateur ou
de chaque producteur pris
individuellement n'a aucune influence
sur le prix final définit par
l'équilibré du marché les offreurs
comme les acheteurs s'ils veulent
obtenir ou vendre le produit sont
obligés d'accepter les conditions du
marché ont cela on dit que les
entreprises sont preneuses de prix la
troisième condition pour définir une
concurrence comme pure et parfaite et la
liberté d'entrer sur le marché pour une
nouvelle entreprise il faut qu'elle
cesse y soit totale les entreprises
présentes ne peuvent pas empêcher
l'arrivée de nouveaux entrants
cette hypothèse est qu'ils voient
supposé l'absence de barrières à
l'entrée
non pas payer un droit ni des coûts
d'installation tellement élevé que
personne ne sait les fournir néanmoins
dans la réalité faire sa place sur un
marché prend du temps quel que soit le
marché considérées
la quatrième condition c'est que toutes
les entreprises doivent offrir un
produit identique équivalent on dit que
le produit est homogène il n'y a pas de
différenciation possible entre les
produits que ça soit au travers une
marque ou le marketing qui est derrière
elle la publicité par exemple et enfin
les consommateurs et les producteurs
d'ipo disposent chacun d'une information
parfaite sur les conditions du marché
chacun s'est parfaitement quel est le
prix du moment quel est le prix du
marché et quelles sont les opportunités
que ce soit les offreurs où les
demandeurs tout le monde connaît ce
qu'est un bon prix vous rendez bien
compte que ces conditions sont très
restrictives est très stricte
donc il ya très peu de secteurs dans
l'économie réelle voire aucun qui dans
la pratique satisfont complètement à ses
principes pendant certains marchés de
produits agricoles tels que celui des
légumes frais ou des céréales s'en
rapproche quand même d'une manière assez
importante malgré le peu d'exemples
qu'on peut trouver dans la réalité du
terrain
le seul modèle de concurrence pure et
parfaite joue quand même un rôle très
important dans les analyses et les
politiques économiques et en sciences
économiques
ce modèle offre d'abord à un cadre
simplifiée qui permet de comprendre le
monde réel
en ce sens c'est un modèle un idéal type
qui nous permet de rendre compte des
choses telles qu'elles se déroulent ce
modèle peut être aussi utilisé comme un
étalon pour évaluer les imperfections du
marché réel donc on compare par rapport
à cette situation idéale entre
guillemets les situations réelles il
peut de ce fait aider les états aient
les différents hommes politiques surtout
quand ils sont baignées d'une influence
libérale à prendre des décisions et à
faire en sorte que l'économie si elle
n'arrive pas à une situation de
concurrence pure et parfaite
ils tendent aux maximes ce stade on peut
se poser une question est ce que cette
perfection est souhaitable
est ce qu'on doit rechercher une
concurrence pure et parfaite
tout d'abord il faut se méfier du mot
parfait l'adjectif parfait dans
l'expression d'une concurrence pure et
parfaite ne signifie pas que cette forme
de concurrence est la meilleure ce n'est
pas parce que la concurrence est plus
parfaite et qu'elle se situe à
l'extrémité du spectre de la concurrence
que nous avons vus en classe qu'elle est
nécessaire nécessairement désirable il
est par exemple possible de fabriquer
une bombe parfaite ou un virus mortel
parfait mais ces deux éléments bien que
parfait ne sont pas souhaitables
collectivement le danger de cette
expression pure et parfaite fait qu'on
peut penser que c'est la solution idéale
ce à quoi on doit tendre et qu'il n'y a
pas d'autre possibilité
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut entendre
le terme parfait ici on veut dire
parfaite dans le sens de total c'est à
dire que la concurrence est vraiment
parfaite
la concurrence est vraiment total il ya
aucune entrave à celle ci donc ça je
vous demande évidemment de bien faire
attention avec l'utilisation de ce thème
parfait modèle de concurrence pure et
parfaite n'existe pratiquement pas dans
la réalité
y à t'il comme un désavantage a essayé
de tendre vers ce modèle
oui il peut y avoir des avantages
activités pour l'intérêt général
tout d'abord c'est le modèle de
concurrence pure et parfaite va vraiment
permettre une sélection des entreprises
les mieux adaptés donc celles qui sont
mal gérées ou celle qu'ils ont qui ont
des produits vraiment défaillant ou qui
ne répondent pas à la demande seront
émis l'idée c'est un petit peu la loi de
la nature pour cela ce qui est
intéressant à ce moment ci pour les
ménages c'est que le modèle de
concurrence libre
pure et parfaite va garantir les prix
les plus bas
donc pour les ménages évidemment qui ont
un revenu plafonner ou limiter cet
intérêt intéressant puisque leur pouvoir
d'achat va augmenter
en ce sens les matières premières sont
actuellement à des prix plancher autour
desquels on ne peut quasi plus descendre
puisque les producteurs produisent déjà
à perte les intérêts des agriculteurs
n'arrivent pas à couvrir leurs coûts
avec les revenus de leur production et
enfin un troisième élément qui fait
qu'émettre à mettre au bénéfice de ce
modèle de concurrence c'est le fait que
l'offre va sans cesse s'adapter à la
demande puisque les offreurs essaye de
trouver des produits adaptés à la
demande
on va vraiment avoir quelque chose qui
est flexible et qui va permettre de
s'adapter mais parce qu'il y a un mais
il ya un gros inconvénient au modèle de
concurrence pure et parfaite
c'est à dire que ce modèle empêche les
économies d'échelle les économies
d'échelle sont quelque chose de très
important pour la rentabilité des
entreprises
en effet imaginons une société qui a
deux bureaux dans des villes à ses
proches
à ce moment elle va se réfléchir à la
verte et indécis je regroupe toutes mes
activités dans un seul bureau
est-ce que je ne vais pas faire des
économies c'est à dire que je ne vais
publier qu'un seul loyer je vais en
avoir qu'une seule équipe de femmes de
ménage pour entretenir mon bâtiment
je n'aurais qu'une seule cantine où je
devrais qui fait tout tout le matériel
pour les cafés pour les machins comme ça
je n'aurais besoin ben finalement que de
certains pc parce que certains jours dès
que des travailleurs des employés ne
viennent pas travailler parce que voilà
ils sont ils n'ont pas
un horaire complet donc ils restent chez
eux certains jours je ferais travail et
d'autres employés quand il y avait deux
bureaux ce n'était pas possible parce
que à ce moment là que je n'étais pas au
même endroit au bon moment
donc voilà c'est tout ça qui va
permettre de réaliser des économies
d'échelle plus je suis gros finalement
plus des choses me coûte relativement
moins cher par rapport aux quantités le
jeu de leurs produits voient toute
l'activité que je dois faire et donc ses
économies d'échelle ne sont pas
possibles avec le modèle de concurrence
pure et parfaite
pourquoi les entreprises qui doivent
atteindre une taille importante enfin
afin de pouvoir bénéficier pleinement
des économies d'échelle et donc de
produire au minimum de leur coût moyen
ce n'est pas possible parce que la
concurrence pure et parfaite requiert un
grand nombre d'entreprises et lesquels
doivent donc généralement restés de
petite taille et les économies d'échelle
c'est raincourt si vous voulez les
grandes tailles donc dans la plupart des
valeurs du parti qu'un les entreprises
sont trop petites pour profiter des
économies d'échelle dans le cadre d'une
économie où la concurrence serait
uniquement sur est parfait lorsqu'une
entreprise est suffisamment grande pour
bénéficier d'économies d'échelle elle
obtient généralement alors à ce
moment-là un pouvoir de marché alors là
j'en prends une notion qu'on a vu au
cours et elle est capable d'évincer les
plus petites structures en proposant des
prix plus bas par exemple et la
concurrence pure et parfaite et de ce
fait détruites donc si vous voulez une
fois qu'il ya un loup dans la bergerie
ben le loup ils mangent les boutons donc
les petites entreprises disparaissent
une par une et le loup est de plus en
plus lourd finalement donc en somme la
concurrence pure et parfaite ne peut
subsister que dans des secteurs où il
n'y a pas d'économies d'échelle possible
là il ya vraiment un lien de causalité
entre les vieux il fallait ne retenir
que certains points de cet exposé que
devez vous retenir
et bien tout d'abord les cinq hypothèses
d'une concurrence pure et parfaite ça me
semble tout à fait indispensable ensuite
bien vous mettre dans la tête que quand
on parle de parfaits ça ne veut pas dire
que c'est la solution parfaite mais
plutôt que c'est un modèle de talent
où il n'y a plus aucune entrave à la
concurrence la concurrence est vraiment
livrées à elles mêmes
le modèle de l'offre et la demande est
vraiment délier il a plus aucune aucune
barrière
enfin les avantages et les inconvénients
bien sûr de ce modèle de concurrence
pure et parfaite sont également des
éléments qui peuvent être pointées vos
notes devrait comporter les éléments
suivants qui est un lexique à maîtriser
c'est à dire que dans le cadre d'une
évaluation quand une application vous
est demandé que vous utilisez ces termes
là plutôt que des mots de tous les jours
il y à une atomicité des agents les
preneurs de prix des produits homogènes
la liberté d'entrer et enfin les
économies d'échelle et bien sûr si vous
avez encore des questions sur cet exposé
n'hésitez pas à les noter d'ailleurs
cette indispensable également que vous
veniez avec vos questions pourquoi nous
puissions débattre au cours
j'espère que vous avez tout compris
j'espère aussi que vous avez quand même
pris des notes pour qu'il reste des
traces de cette vidéo
et n'oubliez pas de répondre tout de
suite au mini test sur ce coup logis qui
vous voir votre bonne compréhension
en tout cas des éléments de base de cet
exposé je vous souhaite un bon travail
et à bientôt
et ça
il
j'ai tout eu
m
il
attention
m
je ne sais pas